[Music]
dear friends i came across a very
very a very bizarre video yeah and i
thought i will share this
with you guys because it's
i'm assuming they're muslim yeah they
have to be muslim yeah for them to even
do this this is very bizarre very very
bizarre um
so here's the cctv footage that keep an
eye on that
i think there's a brother uncle there
walking here okay so a bmw pulls up
they must have had prior knowledge okay
so somebody comes out the car here we go
runs up to him and oh damn look look
look
he just takes his back yeah she takes it
back yeah the bag is full
the bag is full of money yeah is it is
he's like an uncle yeah and is he saying
something he's probably
maybe saying i don't know if he probably
mentioned here
like where the money belongs et cetera
but so you can see
they speed off and go now this is
another video this is very interesting
it's really interesting here
we didn't know that it was mosque money
we would never run from a mosque it's
just based on false information
and he lives right over there
doing a little job yeah burning off
those calories
around calories yeah
they should go to this house but they
know where the guy lives but this
is some intel man mi6 needs some uh
some of these things look at that
okay so that's where the video ends here
i don't know if i should laugh or cry at
this matter it was it was a very very
strange one yeah so good laugh and then
cry
oh you can cry and then laugh you know
yeah you know i don't know man like what
goes through your mind like i know i
know how i feel about it but like what's
what goes to your mind when you're like
when you see that happening so they feel
that it's
okay to steal from a muslim yeah yeah
especially you you know you out of
respect you called him uncle
and that's because he does he's got the
shallower
and doesn't look exactly very young and
if let's face it if he was young you
would have chased after them or done
something uncle's powerless yeah
stealing from an uncle i mean how low do
you have to get and then on the other
hand
they find out it's a masjid oh no no no
this is where we draw the line
here yeah to be fair it's good they drew
the line
yeah yeah show their principles yeah it
shows that they it shows they have some
hope
yeah because some people wrote they
don't care whether it's a masjid or
whether it's a person
yeah so there is if they are watching
you know alhamdulillah there is some
hope
yeah but for you to say that it's you
know okay to steal from a muslim that's
a problem and that's what i'm sure
you're going to elaborate
yeah you know i find it bizarre because
i had to ring with my teacher and just
double check with them
is the the thinking is wrong because
what they're doing is they're saying
okay if it wasn't for a masjid
they would have robbed the muslim man or
any muslim for that matter here
um they would rob it but actually if in
islam
which one is more severe well both of
them are wrong stealing is wrong and the
punishment for that
is specific like you know if you really
read shah salah's book on his
establishment
you know you need to understand that
stealing is not if somebody's walking
around with money in their hand
the [ __ ] is very specific yeah because
if you're kind of having
money in your hand here you're kind of
provoking in some sense
but the thing is the money has to be
locked up we're talking about it's
locked up in your house somebody has to
break
in force entry go to that spot take it
it has to be a specific amount
then there's other things in place that
constitutes theft
rather than you know there's different
like but with this one you can even say
this is like a bit like
allah mentioned about the highway
robbers you know you're stopping someone
on the main on the road you're stopping
and you're asking for it
and allah is very severe in surah maidah
verse 32 like very severe you know kind
of the limbs from either side yeah
that's if they kill somebody and steal
but it changes it's four different
rulings based on what they do
if they come steal don't kill if they
steal and kill
if they don't steal uh uh and just kill
and if they
there's there's four different rulings
i'm talking i'm going to here but i
don't get into that
but what's very strange is that if these
guys are watching this they might be
watching this here
the rights of the muslim is more severe
than you taking money from like let's
say a building let's say a masjid yeah
because when it comes to repentance we
say you stop the sin you hate the sin
you don't go back to it
that's if you've done a sin against
yourself yeah you this is the three
conditions
the scholars say the fourth condition is
that you have to if you've wronged
someone if you stole from someone you've
harmed someone you've backbitten someone
or you found something there you have to
ask for their forgiveness
yeah it's so specific that they say if
you are going to if i if i back by to
jonah came and said to you
i back where did you if i know that's
going to bring more harm i'm not even
allowed to tell you i'm supposed to
repent
and speak good of you or somehow you
know you get them trying to say how this
the charity is specific
not to hurt your feelings when your
feelings are hurt you i need to ask your
forgiveness
and even so if a woman is slandered and
you know this punishment is 80 lashes
yeah
but it is only applicable if that woman
they go to the woman and say this person
is back within you
do you forgive them what the punishment
they have a right to say you know what i
forgive them
you get it so their understanding was
totally like oh no this is money holy ah
well allah is telling you that for
example to take the rights of somebody
who's worked hard
who's feeding their family it's it's
more severe than for you to go and take
and they're both wrong i'm not saying
they're both they're both wrong but the
huck of the person this is something
that you're going to be questioned on
their judgment there's a specific place
we're going to all be in back here
and there anyone that you wrong that's
the final spot before you go to jannah
anyone that you've wronged you're gonna
have to somehow if you've
you know if you've taken from there
whatever it may be you're gonna come in
if you've got no good deeds left
you're gonna carry their bad deeds do
you get it so the thing is in a nutshell
the understanding is that from the
get-go is wrong even if it was a masjid
money you're basically telling me if it
was a massive money he was not going to
return the money
like oh it's uh come on in fact
the rights of the yeah of of the
worshipers the believers
yeah it's um it's very severe yes
yeah now you've done something wrong you
can ask allah for forgiveness but when
is
the rights of the people yeah like you
said yeah back fighting and
returning money like you borrowed money
and
uh it's it's gone beyond the date you
haven't returned it you can ask the
person for forgiveness yeah
yeah ask allah forgiveness but you have
to return that money back yes yeah
when it comes to money it's very
important that you mention the day of
judgment because you will not be allowed
to enter jannah until your affairs
have been rectified and sorted out yeah
and that's not some
that's not a place that we need to be
lingering about yeah exactly
like it's even the prophets even the the
angels will be
you know timid and uh shrinking and
scared
yeah yeah they're sinless but they'll be
afraid of allah's questioning on that
day yeah the prophets
they'll be saying nafsi nafsi me me me
yeah yeah
and it will only be one individual
who will you know take it upon himself
yeah allah will be incredibly angry on
that day yeah yeah and you know what
this is
this is one thing that kind of got to me
and made me practicing as well
just learning about the hereafter yeah i
know sometimes we
we our lifestyles or our desire for the
dunya
overcome our rationality and senses but
we really do need to put things
under perspective because you that money
wallahi
by allah that money will not bring you
in this world and in the hereafter it's
a double loss
yeah yeah if you were a true businessman
yeah a rightly minded individual
you would not resort to this yeah
because i can i i can tell you for a
fact
why because our creator has told us in
our instruction manual
that wealth like that will not bring you
happiness exactly and just just to
finish off
is that you were these brothers if
they're watching this you know maybe
maybe maybe the people that watch our
videos we don't know
you need to understand that when you're
stealing you're genuinely
not you're not you're not gaining
anything in the context where
don't think that extra two thousand or
five thousand that you stole
it's a surplus in your life it's not if
what's the surplus is the sin that you
accumulate
and the money that you stole was going
to reach you that was destined for you
to reach you in a way um you
had the decision to pick that to be in a
halal way or harambe
so if you decided that to be in a haram
way
then you've accumulated sin you haven't
gained anything extra
so bear that in mind if you're stealing
anyone from anything
which is absolutely wrong from anybody
that you haven't really gained anything
you have just gotten what was destined
for you you just chose to
achieve it in a haram way and if all
you've done is under their judgment
you're going to be bankrupt so why don't
you put your trust in allah
go work like everybody else does and
allah will give you
whatever is written for you inshallah
and that's it promises that's what i
want to share with you guys i just found
it very bizarre but it was
interesting hope you guys learned from
this and inshallah this brothers
actually you know whoever they are you
know may allah guide all of us you know
where they're going to be they'll be
better than us in the future if they
might repent you don't know
yeah inshallah sisters inshallah i hope
you guys are benefited from this until
next time assalamualaikum